my name is Stuart Duncan but I'm
actually probably better known online as
autism father that's me on the internet
I know the resemblance is uncanny but
I'm going to talk a little bit today
about Minecraft
that's my minecraft character but if you
don't know the game very well don't
worry too much about it it's just a
medium that I used at the time to fill a
need and what I want to talk about
applies to pretty much every situation
so about four years ago I started a
minecraft server for children with
autism and their families and I called
it at craft and since then we've been in
the news all around the world on
television and radio and magazines
BuzzFeed called us one of the best
places on the internet we're also the
subject of an award-winning research
paper called appropriating minecraft as
an assistive technology for youth with
autism it's a bit of a mouthful but you
get the idea I think so I want to talk a
little bit about that research paper and
what it's about but first I have to give
you a little bit of history on how the
server came to be back in 2013 everybody
was playing Minecraft kids and adults
alike with and without autism of course
but it was the big thing but I saw
parents on social media reaching out to
other parents asking if their autistic
children could play together and the
reason is that when they tried to play
on public servers they kept running into
bullies and trolls when you have autism
you behave a little differently
sometimes sometimes a lot differently
and we all know that a little bit of
differences all you really need for a
bully to make you their next target so
these terrible terrible people online
they would destroy everything that they
tried to make they would steal all their
stuff and they would kill them over and
over again making the game virtually
unplayable but the worst part the part
that really hurt the most was what these
bullies would say to these kids they had
called them rejects and defects and
retards and they would tell these kids
some as young as 6 years old
society doesn't want them and their own
parents never wanted a broken child so
they should just kill themselves and of
course these kids you'd understand they
would sign off from these servers angry
and hurt they would break their
keyboards they quite literally hate
themselves and their parents felt
powerless to do anything so I decided I
had to try and help I have autism
my oldest son has autism and both my
kids and I love Minecraft so I have to
do something so I hate got myself a
minecraft server and I spent some time
built a little village some roads and a
big walk inside and this guy and a lodge
up on a mountaintop he tried to make it
inviting the idea was pretty simple I
had a whitelist so the only people that
I approved could join and I would just
monitor the server as much as I could
just to make sure that nothing went
wrong now was it that was the whole
promise just to keep the kids safe so
that they could play when it was done I
went to Facebook and posted pretty
simple message just on my friends list
not publicly I just wanted to see if
there was actually any interest in this
and if it really could help turns out
that I greatly underestimated just how
much this was needed because within 48
hours I got 750 emails I don't have that
many Facebook friends within 8 days I
had to upgrade the hosting package 8
times from the bottom package the most
expensive package they had and now
almost four years later I have 8,000
names on the white list from all around
the world but the reason I'm up here
today to talk to you isn't just because
I gave kids a safe place to play it's
what happened while they played I
started hearing from parents who said
that their children were learning how to
read and write from playing on the
server at first they spelled things the
way they sound like most kids do but
because they're a part of a community
they saw other people spelling the same
words properly and they just picked it
up I started hearing from parents who
said that their nonverbal children were
starting to speak they only talked about
Minecraft but they were talking
some kids were making friends at school
for the first time ever some are
starting to share and even give things
to other people there's amazing and that
every single parent came to me instead
of is because of odd craft is because
what are you're doing but why though how
could all of this be just from video
game server well that goes back to that
research paper that I was talking about
in it she covers some of the guidelines
that I use when I created the server
guidelines that I think help encourage
people to be their very best I hope for
example communication that can be tough
for kids with autism can be tough for
grownups without autism but I think that
kids should not be punished they should
be talked to you nine times out of ten
when the kids on the server act out it's
because of something else has happened
in the day at school or at home maybe a
pet died sometimes it's just a simple
miscommunication between two children
they don't tell the other person what
they're about to do and so we just offer
to help we always tell the children on
the server that we're not mad and
they're not in trouble we only want to
help and it shows that not only do we
care but we respect them enough to
listen to their point of view respect
goes a long way plus it shows them that
they have everything they need to be
able to resolve these problems on their
own in the future and maybe even avoid
them because you know communication on
most servers has videogames our children
are rewarded while players are rewarded
for how well they do in a competition
right the better you do the better
reward you get that sort of thing can be
automated the server does the work the
code is there on our craft we don't do
that we have things like Player of the
Week and CBA's which is copying awesome
wery we award players ranks on the
servers based on the attributes that
they exhibit such as the buddy ranked
for people that are friendly towards
others and junior helper for people that
are helpful towards others we have
senior helper of the get parent for the
adults but they're exactly they're
obvious right like people know what to
expect and how to earn these things
because of how they're named as soon as
the somebody signs onto the server they
know that they're going to be rewarded
for who they are and not what they can
do our top award the autism father sword
which is named after me because I'm the
founder is a very powerful sword that
you can't get in the game any other way
than to show
you completely put the community above
yourself and that compassion and
kindness is at the core who you are
we've given away quite a few of those
swords actually I figure if we're gonna
watch the server to make sure nothing
bad happens we should also watch for the
good things that happen and reward
people for them we're always trying to
show all the players that everybody is
considered to be equal even me but we
know that we can't treat people equally
to do that some of the players get angry
very easily some of them have additional
struggles on top of autism such as OCD
or Tourette's so I have this knack of
remembering all of the players I
remember their first day and the
conversations we've had things we talked
about and that they've built and so when
somebody comes to me with a problem I
handled that situation differently than
I would with any other player based on
what I know about them for the other
admins and helpers we document
everything so that whether it's good or
bad or a concerning conversation it's
there so everybody is aware I want to
give you one example was one player he
was with us for a little while but at
some point he started spamming dashes in
the chat like a big long line of dashes
all the way across the screen and a
little while later he'd do it again and
so the other players asked him not to do
that he'd say okay and then he'd do it
again so I started to frustrate the
other players they asked me to mute him
or to punish him for breaking the rules
but I knew there had to be something
more to it so I went to his aunt who's
the contact that I have for him and she
explained that he had gone blind in one
eye and was losing his vision in the
other so what he was doing was splitting
up the chat into easier to see blocks of
text which is pretty smart so that very
same night I talked to a friend of mine
who writes code and we created a brand
new plugin for the server that makes it
so that any player on the server
including him of course could just enter
a command and instantly have every
single line separated by dashes plus
they can make it asterixis or blank
lines or anything they want they want
whatever works best for them we even
went a little bit extra and made it so
that it highlights your name so that
it's easier to see if somebody mentions
you it's just one example of how doing a
little bit extra small modification
still helps everybody be on equal
footing even though you did a little
extra just for that one player the big
one is to be not afraid the children on
my server are not afraid they are free
to just be themselves and it's because
we support and encourage and celebrate
each other we all know what it feels
like to be the outcast and to be hated
simply for existing and so when we're
together on the server we're not afraid
anymore
for the first two years or so on the
server I talked to two children per week
on average that were suicidal but they
came to me because I'm the one that made
them feel safe they felt like I was the
only person in the world they could talk
to so I guess my message is whether you
have a charity or some other
organization or your teacher or a
therapist or your parent who's just
doing your very best or you're an
autistic like I am no matter who you are
you absolutely must help these children
strip away those fears before you do
anything else because anything else is
going to feel forced unless they're not
afraid it's why positive reinforcement
will always do better than any form of
punishment they want to learn when they
feel safe and happy
it just happens naturally they don't
even try to learn these are words from
the kids on the server to describe the
service the one thing I would hope that
you could take away is that no matter
what somebody else is going through in
life right now whether they're being
bullied at school or at home if they're
questioning their sexuality or even
their gender which happens a lot in the
autism community if they're feeling
alone or even suicidal you have to live
your life in such a way that that person
feels like they can come to you and tell
you they have to feel perfectly safe in
talking to you about it if you want to
see a group of autistic children kids
whose society wrongly thinks they're
supposed to be antisocial and lacking in
empathy you want to see them come
together and build the most
compassionate and friendly and generous
community you've ever seen the kind of
place that people were right about it
has one of the best places on the
Internet
they'll do that I've seen it I'm there
every day but they have some huge
obstacles that they have to overcome to
do that and it would be really helpful
to have somebody there who could help to
show them that the only thing they
really have to fear is self-doubt so I
guess I'm asking you to please be that
person for them
because to them those kids it means
everything thank you very much